[Music]
Neela's him this time
still as it can be
recycle contain so much more the same
unfortunately maybe just a chain
[Music]
singers that are fake but the suits off
never
but you watch it all cuz Disney's got
your balls at the critics time even what
is
Nate snowflake instead
got all the filthy where's the gold what
wasn't half as damn
certain as the cash
[Applause]
the studio will wave here a second time
songs before me why Disney's black
who cares if it blows were rolling in
the true business plan
oh that's it oh wow
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to the final installment of
Disney live-action remake month for the
final one let's talk about one of
Disney's most beloved animated films if
not their most beloved animated film
Beauty and the Beast with its amazing
animation stunning music unforgettable
characters it received a standing
ovation at the New York Film Festival
what's the first anime movie to be
nominated for a Best Picture Oscar and
is regarded by many to be one of the
best animated movies ever if not the
best yea remake that
[Music]
the story of Beauty and the Beast has
been told countless times they've range
from quick children's Cashion's to
unbelievably adult immature to quick
children's gadgets despite them making a
boatload of cash audiences seem split on
this remake some say it just told the
same story - the fresh take in joy
others say it's a charming adaptation
that captures the magic of the original
I say you foolish it knocks is there any
wiggle room for us purists that love the
original so much there's a lot to talk
about so let's get right to it
this is the live-action remake of Beauty
and the Beast no look they change the
logo again remember when they used to be
clever and unique
even though slight changes to the Disney
format are becoming formulaic as before
we get a back story about a selfish
prince who threw parties for only the
most beautiful people and white
bedsheets Wow
that singing is beautiful don't get used
to it never has before
literally line for line an old woman
knocks on the door and asked for shelter
offering him a single roses payment but
she warned him not to be deceived by
appearances when he dismissed her again
the old but he didn't dismiss her again
she just start glowing and he backed off
literally a stained glass window is
being more consistent than you right now
punishment she transformed him into a
hideous beast like seriously the CGI of
him was hideous the prince in his
servants were forgotten by the world for
the Enchantress had erased all memory of
them yes that's how we handle that plat
hole but fear not we will create many
more to confuse you the title was shown
just like in the last film fells home is
shown just like in the last film and the
same song with the same angelic voices
sung just like in the last minute oh
yeah no three you lost me after no three
[Music]
clearly try not to get me back the same
rule bred in the most juice I've done a
whole editorial about Emma Watson's
painful auto-tuning and lack of emotion
but don't worry the auto-tuning
disappears when she talks the lack of
emotion on the other hand I didn't want
to come back are you going any places to
go actually maybe your whole performance
its auto-tune Christ you sell me Stephen
Hawking's voice box
sibel is not only a bookworm but the
only bookworm in town isn't the only
bookworm in town I'm so glad they
decided to humanize her with more faults
but even that's not impressive as
there's only 12 books in this library
slash Church that's like saying you're a
movie buff if you've only seen eight
films and they're all pure flicks now
okay I'll buy you to stop singing sorry
Tina from Bob's Burgers
of course we see the handsome guests on
has the hots for bill having just
returned from battle ever since the war
I felt like I've been missing something
this creative choice adds a lot to
historian character because now it's
something different something you'll
notice very quickly as well the song
numbers clearly have a lot of work put
into them they still somehow seem slow
and lifeless the original has the
advantage of being animated it can
exaggerate everything and get the timing
perfect practically leaping off the
screen but still why does it seem like
there's so little energy here look there
she goes well if I could borrow from
another terrible cinematic musical as
bad as great as Schulman got it still
was quite a spectacle when it came to
the musical numbers this is because not
only is the movement keeping the energy
up but so are the camera angles the
editing and what's being focused on the
majority of beats and every song have
something visual keeping you connected
to it
[Music]
this is just people walking around and
it's shot edited and feels like people
just walking around
[Music]
also bail is the only one who wore blue
and the original helping her stand out
here oh she's from Harry Potter
that's interesting enough wonderful book
you have there have you read it
oh well not that one but you know books
much like the script I didn't read it
look out the one good scene in the movie
[Music]
I'm serious this edition though that's
some very wealth is filled with so much
heart and emotion in this one scene
through lyrics paintings and expressions
we know who he's singing about and what
she meant to our leads without
specifically addressing her tell me one
thing about her except when they do
you're forget ibly bland odd would be a
step up back in Paris I knew a girl like
you who was so different people mocked
her please just tell me one more thing
about her
your mother was sad say it fear this ah
it should've been odd he said how much
he admires uniqueness and how being odd
isn't bad my heart was this close to
melting and what did you go with
fearless oh wow I'm instantly gonna
forget about this scene right so what
can I bring you from the market market
in the originally it was the fair she
was just at the market when the hell are
you travelling a great distance for
what's literally in your front yard he's
at wall market or the price is so good
that we're travelling for arrays like
the one in the painting you asked her
that every year okay bring me a hairy
CGI man with the Rose if we want to
hammer this in and so to add even more
dimension to humanizing belt she
apparently events the washing machine
yeah that's a thing
Wow bell really is Jesus in that Jesus
invented the chair clearly established
in the passion aren't these two popular
enough you don't to have them invent
no in the original Bella seen as
odd because she's a bookworm that keeps
to herself but seeing how that was the
kids version and this one wants to be
more adult let's spell it out even
or what on earth are you doing teaching
another girl to read isn't one enough we
have to tell you something I'm gonna
write up a plan to get her back that is
if I knew how to read or write they do
have an evil plan though they knock over
her washing machine and it's really not
shot like a big deal it's only a few
seconds they don't even focus on her
looking angry and she feeling we're
sorry for this guy the attention seems
to be focused on him people just let
women use washing machines my god that
sounds sexist Beauty and the Beast
guests on approaches Bell and suggests
they become an item but Bell turns down
his wedding proposal despite him never
giving a wedding proposal some of us
have changed I'm never going to marry
you guest on I'm sorry now of course in
the original we see the beginnings of
gasps Dawn's cruel nature and Belle's
frustration reaching her peak here it's
just another scene yeah look at how
angry he looks in the original he says
Belle's gonna be his wife he marches off
super angry after getting this whole big
wedding proposal thing put together here
there's none of it he looks more like
I'm in the mood for nachos maybe pizza
no nachos
belly even goes into her big Madame
Gaston song and it doesn't feel
warranted you see time passed in the
original so you can feel the emotions
rising even when they're not on screen
it also allow for a location change so
you're not getting tired of looking at
the same place for too long but in this
order not only are we stuck in the
village for longer than we need to be
but Belle just comes across as bland
whining after bland whining there's no
break from it
someone
yeah along with your mother back your
father talking about her more girls
reading patenting your washing machine a
rose guest on that asking you to marry
him even though he didn't ask you to
marry him and would've advised don't
smile when you're singing what you're
frustrated about I say this child actor
stuff but you were a child actor Belle's
father gets lost on his way to
presumably the greatest market in the
world and stumbles across the beast
castle he finds it's filled with all
sorts of nightmare utensils oh I mean
two charming little friends as he's
intimidated by the place and escapes
wait wait wait roses Bella Rose I mean
sure this place is haunted I was
pleading for my life but it rose what am
I gonna come across that the beast
captures the father though as the horse
goes back to Belle and she demands that
she's taken to him
[Music]
pleasant weather than horrendous winter
I must be in Chicago such a wide range
of expressions from Watson isn't it in
the enemy of one she holds her father's
belonging close to her and looks worried
here she doesn't even glance at the damn
thing it just looks like she's been
asked a hard math question it's the
square root of 329 hmm
it gets even better when she finds her
father locked up and the Beast confronts
her the film takes what was an emotional
moment of fear and discovery and almost
fast forwards through it look at the
time it takes for every character to
come to their decision Belle has to
think before offering up her life beasts
has to think before realizing he may
have a way out of his damnation the
reveal of him is slow letting her
reaction sink in to what she's about to
do but that movie was an hour and a half
and this is but a mere two hours ten
minutes but we got a bullet point this
quickly offering up her life punish
me not him
check quickly revealing the Beast check
quickly having peace realize what this
could mean oh we didn't even have time
for that okay whatever emotions are
secondary in a romance why is what they
show beast and Belle together as little
as possible not even kidding
remember when the BCS are crying it
feels bad and then decides to give her a
nicer room while also being domineering
how he's trying to be sympathetic
showing some emotion but losing it again
when he brings up the west wing
establishing a mysterious connection to
it going back and forth establishing
what a tortured character he is trying
to be kind but he's too filled up with
anger from years of isolation making
Belle's new environment all the more
uncertain and frightening
the danger fear and captivity feel all
the more real oh god yes really
now it's codsworth and Lumiere doing all
that because they didn't give them much
time earlier for whatever reason we
don't even have a breakdown from Belle
realizing the sacrifice she made she
just walks blandly through the palace
with no fear no intimidation no nothing
oh don't worry though the beast is even
less interesting even taking the way how
distracting his CGI is even though it
originally was gonna be makeup it's like
Superman CGI upper lip except it's the
whole thing but listen to this line from
the original
you thought that perhaps this girl could
be the one to break the spell of course
I have well guess who goddamn is she's
the daughter of a common thief
this beast hates that she's in a nicer
room roaming around the castle and has
to be told that she's the one that could
possibly break the spell you're making
her dinner gave her a pitchman so that's
ridiculous idea I've ever heard Shawn
please okay what the other beast is a
brute but he still has some connection
to an intelligent emotional human being
that's what Belle has to discover this
one's just a dumb ass he's not
intriguing he's not smart there's no
sympathy so there's no relating to him
between both their lack of being
invested in anything I think the real
couple I want to see get together and
this is these two
[Applause]
[Music]
so may our 43 minutes in and we're
finally introduced to mrs. potts god I
love how this movie is structured as
we're given frankly a confusing
connection between the credenza and the
wardrobe maestro your wife is upstairs
finding it harder and harder to stay
awake she's counting on you to help us
break this curse literally that one line
is the only thing that shows those two
characters have a relationship do you
follow it why is she tired what does it
mean that she's tired
why is she upstairs and don't they see
each other or talk to each other at all
the place is big enough that they can
work out something we see her come to
the balcony and the stairs seem big
enough to support either of them why
don't they see each other at all you
know I already have one romance with a
ton of plot holes I don't care about
don't try to shoehorn in another fellas
shown the dining room and we partake of
course in the big showstopper be our
guest leftovers in every meaning of the
word the music number is honestly okay
despite Ewan McGregor as Lumiere is
something like a drunk Pepe LePew
you'll be gas but because there's no
real fear or danger built up this
doesn't feel as much as levity as much
as obligation we're not doing this to
lift the emotional intensity Bell has
gone through because you know that will
require an emotion out of Bell they're
doing it because it'd be crazy not to do
a song this popular plus more creepy
teapot faces
[Music]
I'm gonna drink out of you or you gonna
drink out of me
it ends kind of awkward woody I don't
understand why you're being so kind to
me
surely yours trapped here as I why did
you need that weird cut in the original
she says that was great why don't we
look around the castle it was an easy
Segway it would have been easy to have
that before she walked through the rooms
of sculpted tentacle porn to the West
Wing
Oh oh my god looks just like the other
rooms I mean come on you remember how
destroyed that room looked in the
original it was kind of like whoa what
happened in here but because the rest of
the castle already looks like
architectural clutter this isn't the
least bit jarring I dare even say the
West Wing looks nicer than the other
rooms in the castle dibs on the west
wing but look out an angry beasts with
hastily rush lines seven seconds from
him appearing to her leaving seven
seconds don't get me wrong the original
wasn't that long either but look they're
absorbing their actions taking their
time what they say in do actually has
weight to it amounting to at least a
bare minimum of thirty seconds that's
over double the time of this one you
thinking a longer film they could have
expanded on that but no they actually
make it go quicker freakin quicker
somehow go faster and slower at the same
time as you'd guess Bella's cornered by
wolves and the Beast saves her that was
incredibly emotional animation isn't
that replaced by a glance down okay
careful that's a whole facial muscle you
just use there as we cut to something
new at least guests on trying to help
Marie's fine bail where is Belle the
Beast took her and she no such things as
beasts I'll just be honest I'm not
entirely sure what Gaston endgame is
here he didn't believe Marie so why did
he think he would find Belle did he even
believe she was gone and not at home
maybe he's just trying to get friendly
with I will feed you to the laws maybe
not that's no way to talk to my future
father-in-law now is it you will never
marry my daughter now kindly help me
find her you clearly well balanced human
kneel down I go
so Gaston goes from zero to murder
pretty quick leaving Marie's to be eaten
by the wolves the town Baker finds him
later and nurses him back to health not
entirely sure where this is all going
but I'll wait it out to be disappointed
meanwhile Belle tends to the beasts
wounds as the servants admit that they
were cursed too because they didn't help
when the beasts mean father made him so
foul and he's
father took that sweets I haven't
twisted him out to be just like him
we didn't nothing will of course never
see any of that apart from this
pointless flashback of his mother dying
but that's okay the more we don't show
the beauty and the beast' interacting in
a movie called Beauty and the Beast the
more things will fall into place with
the eyes but with the mind therefore is
we need Cupid oh yeah an hour turn in I
guess we can start having some chemistry
now the other film would only have 20
minutes left
ramune Julius my favourites are so many
better things to read like what a couple
of things in here you could stop me oh
yeah so the Beast doesn't give Belle the
library to show his thanks and that he
understands something she loves he just
accidentally shows it off tried to get
her mind off romance
oh and here's an interesting addition we
become Antiques rubbish yeah if the
spell is broken they don't stay that way
they become actual inanimate objects so
keep saying this but um in the goddamn
original when they're doing the song
numbers and being friendly there's an
underlying fear that they'll stay that
way but they at least have been like
that for years they can survive here
they will literally die why the friggin
hell are you singing and dancing perfect
isn't Belle kind of selfish knowing this
could be their last days and she's just
blocking up with the Beast shouldn't
everyone be in an awkward position right
now what is wrong I'm sorry I just can't
focus on romance right now when this
could be your last night alive oh but we
are happy to serve you there is no
pressure to fall in love with the Beast
what oh nothing I didn't say anything
falling in love with the Beast will
break the curse but you're not supposed
to know that or it's less likely to
happen no no no that's fine I'm glad you
told me I'm just gonna go fall in love
with him and not think about it at all
but Zee knowledge is just going to get
in the way no I'm sure I could make this
work I'll totally I'll make it work
you're right I can't make this work it's
all I can think about to tell you I just
can't get my mind off of it now I don't
even know where the silver candlestick
goes okay I'm gonna go invent the
toaster or something I'm so sorry I
couldn't help
[Music]
we took a legit nice moment with them
talking on a bridge followed by a weird
as hell moment of her getting
sucker-punched by a snowball but we're
giving it another odd edition of finding
out that the Beast has a book that can
literally and I guess literally take him
anywhere
what book truly allows you to escape the
outside world has no place for creature
like me but it can for you someone I
must sleep at you want to escape you
totally can't we just made this even
more of a Stockholm movie they use it to
see where Belle's mother died always a
romantic spot and they never use it
again you know wasn't that the idea of
the mirror the only window to the
outside world
now that window turned into a goddamn
United air flight true they don't treat
dogs well that could be an issue but I
think you can still go places where
there's little to no people isolation my
ass I'll gladly get turned into a beast
if it means I can literally go anywhere
in the world but nope let's stay here
and awkwardly do our ballroom scene that
feels more like two third graders being
forced to hold hands yeah the scene was
pretty romantically laid out in the
original wasn't it they make a whole
evening out of it they eat at the table
he learned how to use a spoon she gets
the idea to go dance but he's nervous
because he clearly doesn't know how so
she teaches him and they both become
comfortable and
each other's arms it feels real it built
up to this lovely moment and it feels
genuine again all skipped just go
straight to the ballroom go down the
stairs turn right that's all people
really want to see just the image not
anything that led up to it house even
proposed if you're not doing anything
tonight I was hoping we could just go to
the ballroom dance for exactly two
minutes and stare blankly at each other
put Italy to this shot that means we're
in love now great plan by the way to
have currently one of the greatest
living singers in your movie and have
Emma Thompson sing your big song I'm
sure McDonald couldn't top end
[Music]
movie Bell sees through the mere though
that Gaston is having her father locked
up not to give Belle to marry him but
just to cover his tracks for trying to
kill him that is so much better way this
faucet he's in trouble
Wow again barely even thought about it
this is actually kind of amazing look at
the same scene in the good movie he was
told he was dying he looks at the Rose
thinks for a moment on the verge of
tears he then tells her she can go he
realizes what he's giving up but he
loves her so much he's willing to make
the sacrifice this sounds more like an
office favor I need a digital copy of
this and Frank is the only one with a
scanner to go to him okay I'll see you
see you on this Scouten no time to waste
that's why I'm having you go on
horseback and not the magic book that
can take you anywhere and bring him
right back he's only solving two
problems but then we couldn't have the
gimme Oscar song
kind of ironic seeing how Disney stole
the Oscar from Disney the song itself is
okay despite it not being very well sung
and I'll even give credit to the kill
the beasts song after Belle convinces
everyone the Beast is real well shot and
keeps the energy very high before the
first half yes go horseback riding I'm
so amped right now hmm the climax is
pretty standard with comedic slabs day
cleaning up to the showdown between the
beast and Gaston though of course
arrives giving him the courage to fight
back
[Music]
granted I have no other name in this
meme and the woman I love calls me Beast
but I just don't want the way you say it
Gaston gets one last shot before falling
to his death the living objects are
turned into inanimate objects and Belle
confesses her love in front of The
Enchantress
[Music]
that's right the Baker woman was the
Enchantress the whole time
and on top of transforming the beast and
everyone back to normal
well mostly normal this blink is weird
she also gives the townspeople back
their memories oh yeah it looks like
some of them have friends and family in
that castle that she kept separated for
years and years this is a goddamn messed
up lady she's gonna punish the servants
with death if the Beast doesn't fall in
love she raised all memory of government
gem families apart pretty much altered
this entire world and for what so they
can learn overcoming prejudice comes
down to beastly violence so she could
let another selfish asshole ruin things
while she watches and does nothing the
dude served in war two why wasn't he
given the beast treatment rather than
just watching him die her secretly
viewing this doesn't make her an
all-knowing angel it makes her a friggin
psychopath she's a goddamn psychopath
this movie is messed up but happily ever
after I guess haha everyone's so happy
just forget the mayhem and terror that
bestowed us Christ and look the best
singer actually gets the finishing song
up
[Music]
Chadd at McDonald you got this voice to
contend with but she got the last note
bitches and that was really hard to get
through the original is a classic
telling of a timeless story this is just
a remake a remake that doesn't
understand what made the original story
so powerful
well it's shorter and arguably simpler
every choice plays a part in driving the
characters motivations the emotions feel
justified and earned this one just
changes things that don't need to be
changed didn't add enough to make it its
own thing and sped up parts that needed
to remain slow it's as if the story is
still there but the wrong parts are
focused on leading to something that
looks familiar but feels false if you
enjoy it more power to you but I can
tell you this is a beast I don't think I
can ever learn to love thank you for
watching Disney's live-action remake
month and I gotta tell you after seeing
all these animated classics turn into
these live-action abominations I got to
see some cartoon that's put to
live-action done right
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out in this week we are doing two
seconds or less two seconds or less as
an organization dedicated to ending
childhood malnutrition with its
sustainable solutions to hunger they put
nutrition gardens at government schools
and educate on nutrition and farming to
empower children to break the cycle of
poverty both at home and around the
world growth in agriculture has at least
twice the potential impact of any other
sector for reducing poverty around the
world it has the ability to support
livelihood through sustainable income
generation and holistic health care
through this program's work students
learn that to grow up and become a
farmer is not a desperate end but a
hopeful beginning if you look at their
site in their YouTube page you can see
all the children being helped in all the
people who work day and night to make
sure they have the strength and energy
they need for the future click on the
link and see what you can do to help a
small child in a big way
[Music]
you